on the mound for the dodgers julio urias
over his last three games he's won them
all he's got a sub 2 era
that includes taking a perfect game into
the sixth against the giants on sunday
in san francisco
slater pokes one right side and pass
pujols for a lead off base hit
they've got slater hung out between
first and second urea says one of the
best pick-off moves
in the national league he's waiting on
this throw from muncie and he wipes the
bases clean
i mean i i just 3-0 count you just got
nowhere to go nothing to do and that
just
i'm not really sure what the thought
process was right there
we talked to gabe kepler before the game
about austin slater he said here's a guy
who has
so much talent that just hasn't quite
put it together
that is cork down the line and another
extra base hit for buster posey
and the pick off lumen large now as
posey cruises into second with a one-out
double
he swings at the first pitch down the
left field line hooking from beatty
slides
and makes the catch matt beatty with a
run-saving play to finish the first
katie with a long run sliding catch
spun held on and made a spectacular play
that hit hits locks on a 1-2
both teams have put the lead off man on
in this first inning
and this slider just continues to dive
in hits him in that back
foot one-on-one out here's turner
on a 2-1 pitch smokes a line drive to
left center field
diving attempt but dubai unable to get
it
it's up against the wall luck setting
for the plate there is no throw
and the dodgers have the game's first
run on a double from justin turner
on a 2-2 smith swings and misses at a
good slider from webb to finish off the
first but a turner double
opens the scoring on to the second now
he throws
and a changeup is ripped down the left
field line base hit hustling over toward
the corner is
beatty to cut it off the big turn at
first by flores but he'll put the brakes
on
and hold on with a single and that ended
the first inning here is
donovan solano and he muscles one into
the shallow left center field area
that's in there for a base hit
floor is over the second and he'll hold
on
crawford hits one on the ground that's
through base it into center field
flores throws on the brakes three
consecutive singles to load them up for
san francisco
here's dubon out of the eighth spot one
nothing game top two
giants have the bases loaded with nobody
out
oh and two on dubai here comes zurious
that's grounded up the middle
and through base it for dubon flores in
to tie the game here comes solano
it's a two-run single and san francisco
leads 2-1
there they go here it comes it is taken
high
ball four that's the part of the game
that grew
so much for mikey stramski last year
here he draws the bases loaded walking
it's three one
to second solano waits on it takes a
tough bounce on it and baby reaches
giants have the fewest heirs in the
majors and solano
with the 18th san francisco air of the
season there
here's first half bat for him since
april 20th
mission more than a month with an
oblique injury
he grounds the first one that he sees
under solano
back-to-back airs on the san francisco
second baseman and it opens the door for
the dodgers to put him at the corners
with one hour
here he squares around lays it down
first base side
baby will come home and so arias has
four rbis in his two games against the
giants and it's 3-2
that's yanked to the left field lead off
base hit for flores who's two for two
here in his first game off of the
injured list
that solano swings and drives this one
out to deep left center field
bellinger going back looking up go on
i would call that making up for those
two errors a two run
homer from donovan solano
his second of the series second of the
year it's five to two giants
on a one-two he lofts a breaking ball
down the left field line
baity was playing way over to the gap
and that's going to fall in for a base
hit
and a two-out double kastremski does it
again with two strikes and keeps this
inning going
nine hits for the giants over three and
two thirds against durians
first one to evan longoria is the
breaking ball swatted through the right
side another base hit for the giants
yasrimski headed home the throw not in
time
and an rbi single for evan longoria
makes it 6-2
he'll take second as the ball gets by
smith
to flores is yet to laugh another
two out hit for the giants longoya is in
to score
rbi single wilmer flores who is three
for three in his first game back
and it's 7-2 san francisco onesie oh for
two
got ahead of him and now home of the
next one now muncie turns on it
sends it in here to right center field
it's gone he gets him again
way up there for max muncie match muncie
with his 12th home run
of the year a high majestic
shot into the sun emblazoned
bleacher seats down in the pavilion it's
7-3
here's another one two smith pulls the
line drive
base head left center pass crawford
two on with one out bellinger at second
smith at first
pujols is over two today
yanks a line drive to left right a
duggar but over his head
and off of the wall bellinger's in to
score
smith stops at third on a double from
pujols
it's 7-4 and the dodgers get the tying
run to the play
another payoff is yanked to right
base hit to start the seventh for wade
to the five spot in the order has gone
four for four
today for the giants lucia homo one
just hate to see guys get hit on the
hand or the wrist because there's so
many little bones
top part of the hand you just hope it
kind of
wasn't flush that just does not feel
good
hopefully he's got some grip strength
there
man he's already got a knot on there
look at that thing yeah well a tough
situation just got tougher for alex
base is now loaded and stephen duggar
coming up
lucia's 2-2 line drive right field down
below
base it for duggar bellinger races over
to get it
a two-run double for steven duggar and
the giants lead 9-4
and a perfect day made by mike
for this young man this is what it's all
about look at that reacts
yeah all fired up got the smile really
that's just a cool move by
mike here's the 2-0 pitch
swing and there's a drive into deep left
field way back there still going and
goodbye
over the wall in a home run for longoria
his eighth of the year his second rbi of
this game and the giants have a 10 to
four lead
the bond lifts one into center for chris
taylor
that is plenty deep to bring home
donovan solano
the giants lead 11-4
smith yanks a line drive base hit over
crawford
[Applause]
11-6 who holds with his seventh home run
of the year
and his second with the dodgers
got him swinging and the giants with
back-to-back wins over the dodgers 11-6
the final in this one